-Welcome back.
We're hanging out
with Amy Schumer,
ladies and gentlemen, now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh. Stop.
Wow.
-Amy...
-Wow. I'm very humble.
-Amy I wanted to mention --
I know.
You said that.
-Very, very humble.
-I know.
-It's one of the best things
about me.
-I know.
-Yeah.
-I did want to mention --
this is a big deal --
you are going
to host the Oscars this year.
-Oh, my God. I am?
-This is a giant deal, yeah.
-This is big.
-Congratulations.
-Me and Regina Hall
and Wanda Sykes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
-Regina Hall and Wanda Sykes.
How did it come about?
Did you immediately say yes?
Like, "This is great.
I'm in," or...?
-Yeah. I was --
I mean, I just feel like
performing right now.
Coming out of the pandemic
and everything,
you know, hopefully --
-Yes.
[ Knocks on wood ]
-I just feel
really excited about it.
I want to go and, you know,
get into some trouble.
-Yeah!
-You know?
-We need trouble.
We need fun.
We need some entertainment.
-Let's go.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-And it's gonna be great, bud.
I want to talk about
"Life & Beth."
-Yes.
-We just had Jon Glaser
on the show --
-Oh, I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no!
I was gonna say
he was fantastic.
-Oh, good!
Oh, good, yeah.
-Gosh, you have a great cast.
-It's ridiculous.
-It is insane.
-It's too much.
-No, it's great.
-I wish I caught their names
while they were there, but...
[ Laughter ]
-They're a really great cast.
"Life & Beth."
But this came about because,
during the pandemic,
you were looking through old,
like, diaries?
What is...?
-Yeah, I mean,
I got weird over the pandemic.
-I think we all did
a little bit.
-You know, yeah,
just in dark, dark places.
And I was just looking back
at my journals
and, like, sort of
the teenage traumas.
And I'm also, like,
a new mom,
and I'm learning that
all toddlers want is empathy.
And surprise, surprise,
that's all adults want, also.
-Yeah. Exactly, right?
-You know?
So, I just thought
it's really important to,
you know, kind of confront
those traumas, and --
in order to move forward.
-Yeah.
-So, I wanted
to make a show about that.
And, uh...
-And you did.
-And somebody said I could,
so I did.
-Do you want to explain
your character
and who you play in the show?
-Yes, I am a supermodel --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I'm a runway model -- no.
Beth is --
I play a woman who works in --
Everything looks really good.
She has a hot boyfriend,
living in Manhattan,
has a cool job
working with wine.
-Yeah.
-But she's miserable.
You know, like,
all these things she thought
that would make her happy
aren't.
-Aren't making her happy.
-Right.
-It's very, very funny.
You guys are gonna enjoy this.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Amy Schumer
in the new show "Life & Beth."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Plan A didn't work out?
-Shut up.
-You must be...Matt?
-Are you in here a lot?
-This is not Matt, okay?
This is Trevor.
-Travis.
-Here. You wanna
just take that now?
-Excuse me?
-Oh, damn.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah, that's exactly right.
Amy Schumer, everybody!
All episodes of "Life & Beth"
will be on Hulu this Friday!